[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants boers crois pas trop
blue
blue ou mais qu'est ce que tu racontes
nounours je ne comprends rien je parle
comme notre petite amie phoque patron
comme nounou
ou cloud ou lou lou mais que dis tu
je dis que je descend vite raconté une
histoire de nous à mes petits amis
mon échelle et hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop
[Musique]
bonsoir
zanou tu nous raconter l'histoire une
histoire de loup oui une nouvelle
aventure de loulou le petit foc
ragga la santé cher ami un instant je me
pose
là écoutez moi attentivement nous
écoutons amis et lens et l'as et lens
autant le petit allemand 10r en sagesse
autant loup grandisse un mets pas en
sagesse
le printemps venu le petit garçon on ne
naît tous les jours son foc à la plage
quelle joie pour nous que de plonger au
milieu des vagues de
se rouler dans le sable fin qui est de
faire mille facéties pendant que yann
ramasser des coquillages à ce qu'ils
étaient mesa un jour louvie brillé à la
surface de l'eau une belle bouille toute
ronde qu'est ce que c'était ou le au
ballon et l'oubli plongea le loup le
loup revient ici crier gare il n'est
guère obéissent à ces jeunes femmes au
salon et poussins et flore le pouce et
en entraînant la boule de verre
loulou ce prix dans le filet que le
marin pêcheur breton avait posé le matin
et on sache dans gigotant et se
tortillant il déchira le filet à
poissons et revint sur la plage tous
coeurs avec la boule de verre
en équilibre sur le deux
loulous villa loulou tu as abîmé le
filet de pêche de papa tu vas être
gronder les grandes et
très fort mais il savait se faire
pardonner si gentiment que le marin
pêcheur breton pour faire plaisir à son
fils par donna il faut te jo pardonner
et tandis que le soleil se couchait sur
la petite île fait de simples de
coquillages et devront le marin pêcheur
breton assis sur l'a10 dupas
raccommoder son beau fils est déchiré et
voilà l'histoire est terminée
déjà elle était très jolie machine
mbokolo toulousaine est libre d'y tenir
merci merci chers amis je me sauve ma
fille
bonne nuit mes amis dollars ou lausanne
lui de nous tous mes voeux vous
accompagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lolll paul collier bien gai notre de nos
fruits patron je suis content le vieux
bbl vous ne trouvez pas oui nounours la
vie est très belle on y va en route 28
des enfants fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
et